Australian Prime Minister Scott Morrison
seen for himself
the latest areas devastated by bush
fires in New South Wales the day after
he was confronted by angry residents in
the town of Kabongo this woman refusing
to shake his hands the prime minister
said he wanted to offer comfort to those
affected by fires on New Year's Eve and
he's not surprised at their reaction
people are angry it is something that I
will empathize with it is something that
I understand it's not something for me
to take personally it's peak holiday
season but with the state of emergency
declared in the states of New South
Wales and Victoria tens of thousands of
people have been leaving tourist areas
traffic's been backed up for many
kilometres on major highways as people
try to get home or at least to safer
areas about a quarter of the 4,000
people stranded on a beach in the town
of mallacoota in Victoria have been
taken on board naval vessels to escape
the fires haven't been a processor know
well down at the foreshore and it's
something that I want to forget the
evacuations will continue as fire
conditions on Saturday a forecast to be
catastrophic we're making every
preparation possible for what will be a
very difficult day tomorrow weather
conditions are very unpredictable we
know the temperatures will still be in
the mid 40s in many parts of our state
thousands of firefighters are in the
field with additional helicopters on
standby we're unfortunately very likely
we will lose homes tomorrow but we'll be
very happy and we'll call it success if
there's no lives lost that is our single
focus tomorrow a focus on saving lives
in the face of an unprecedented bushfire
season
Felicity Davie al Jazeera Sydney